i'm natalie i'm chantelle and i'm chris
we're trying to find chantelle a man is
this actually i don't know i haven't
decided yet
sorry barnacles
i feel like you can tell a lot about a
guy just based on his credit card
statement i agree it's financial
responsibility we could be a little bit
flexible on that though you know because
like we're in new york city we're young
so financial responsibility and balling
out on
passionate things exactly exactly are we
good a little bit yeah
so one are you paying the bills bro but
are you also turning up because life is
all about balance natalie and i are
gonna help chantelle figure out who she
wants to go on a date with based on two
guys credit card statements do you think
a credit card statement is a good way to
screen someone for dating it might be a
good way to screen someone out for
dating yeah i don't know if it's a great
way to screen someone in so you can look
for red flags but once you filter out
the red flags it's really anyone's game
right yeah what do you think your credit
card statement says about you it says
i'm a wholesome person who likes alcohol
what are you expecting to see today
probably get judged very hard you could
think really whatever you want it could
be like uber you know it could be gas
for driving it could be it could be
anything so there was a supreme in there
you know so they might see if you know
what it is like oh i'm okay he got some
swag because that's kind of one of those
like if you know you know kind of you're
for the culture
100 for the courtship so we do it for if
you got a credit card you know you
you're somewhat focused at least you're
trying to let you try to build your
credits or you like taking on too much
debt
right right yeah
all right so this is dude number one
this is his credit card statement from
march 15th to april 13th wait first of
all if you look at his total statement
his balance was five thousand dollars so
he spent about five thousand dollars in
a month well that probably means he has
a really high credit limit so i respect
that dude he has good credit you know or
he's way past his limit yeah well we
need to see the credit card score too to
get like the full visibility he went to
a place called nudes with like five o's
you know he a little quirky
quirky not terrible he also went to a
place called sauced and he spelled forty
dollars there do you think for forty
dollars he got sauce that sauce no doubt
yeah
without a question though he spends a
lot of time in brooklyn and i like that
dude because brooklyn people are so dope
like a bit of a blanket statement but
yeah spends a lot of time because i live
there
well food how much do you spend at whole
foods forty dollars i like a man that
goes to whole foods
wait hold up he went to fig 19.
guys if you don't know what fake
nineteen is like you suck the finest
establishment in new york city like that
they know that
designed specifically for people our age
who are into 90s bangers yeah he's
pretty outgoing so far okay he went to
sushi by m and put his card down i love
that he put his card down for omakase i
lost a bet to my roommate so i had to
buy a sushi they don't know that they
don't know that you put your car down in
their eyes put my car down they don't
have to know that the sushi by m
transaction is 334. i'm a sushi by m fan
shout out to sushi by m i love you guys
he goes to sauced a lot what is sauce uh
dude i would like to know as well what
is sauce i've been sauced but i don't
know if i've been too soft it's a wine
bar definitely getting sauced definitely
getting salsa sauce that's the running
joke is this like the m like the subway
yeah he's doing the the tap on the metro
so he takes the subway he loves taking
the subway that means he's financially
responsible because he's not ubering
everywhere like if i was sauced at
sauced would you call us an uber or
would you make me take the subway for 40
minutes to brooklyn because it seems
like you live in brooklyn you have a
peacock subscription no one has a
peacock subscription
why do they come in damn they're roasted
bro yeah they play
they play soccer games on there
doesn't care to do what everyone else is
doing he's doing his own thing he's a
little off the beaten path i like that
do you think he's a hipster would you
consider yourself a hipster
i feel like that term has been
put through the the washing machine
i don't know i don't think that's you in
the right place yeah i don't know i
guess reluctant reluctantly reluctantly
does the number of transactions here say
anything about him big baller big baller
but i didn't see anything that was
ridiculously expensive though a casual
baller right exactly i take the subway
that's what i'm saying oh he got the
amex
the amx platinum
i see you he likes the finer things in
life but also like the chiller things in
life oh [ __ ] he he subscribes to the new
york times oh educated
interested he said current events oh
wait he had turbo tax he did taxes he
did it on march 26th he's way ahead of
schedule right that's impressive you do
your taxes yet oh you've been yeah yeah
for sure yeah well i was on it couple
guys to do our taxes yeah actually dude
this is not financially irresponsible
enough for me they're saying that you're
not balling out why are you not balling
out
yeah i need like more crazy purchase
there's no there's no bust down on it
like why yeah no bus downs no there's no
maru there's no doubt
no like thousand dollar bottle at the
club i appreciate this but like where is
the financial irresponsibility but so
far who is this guy how are you feeling
about him do you want to go on a date
with him i like brooklyn boy i would say
his brand is like understated opulence
like he's like low-key but he's like
kind of a baller is my table like a
modest ball like a modest a modest
baller he's the type to buy like
designer items with no logos on them
low-key baller
you're low-key with your brother i like
low-key ball you don't want to be
high-key about anything you know i agree
like i agree all right all right all
right broken boy overall you're feeling
this guy yeah all right do you want to
move on to the next one yes
oh hell yeah hell yeah oh yeah i told
you it was i was in a little situation
so i couldn't use my cards a lot okay
this is interesting what is union 76 oh
so he drives he drives
gasoline oh it's gas but it's like it's
like pre-paid though because like it's
like 25 each time oh very difficult
how much did you spend at supreme bro
okay he bought a shirt at supreme i
respect that was it a shirt a certain
hat i think
the merchant category for all these
transactions except for that supreme
shirt is gasoline so he probably doesn't
live in new york maybe oh he lives in
jersey it could be reasons why someone
only uses their credit card for gasoline
rather than spending oh he can be one of
those people who like has a different
credit card for each like type of
purchase yeah so maybe this is his gas
credit card
now they're cooking thank you how
different do you feel this guy is from
the previous guy first guy's an open
book this guy this guy's more secretive
man more mysterious more mysterious wow
i told look i'm on the run you know
that's all they know is i'm active gas
and supreme what an interesting combo
like yeah
okay you're you're obviously from jersey
does jersey get popping this guy drives
a lot so he has a car i love car drives
and you know what someone does when they
drive a lot listen to music they listen
to music so he probably has good music
taste and he like we're supreme so like
he's probably like you know for the
culture okay you're for the culture 100
for the courtship
also you're spending specifically 25 on
gas is that a little is that a lot that
doesn't even fill up a tank but if you
have a prius bro that's like almost a
full tank oh so you care about the
environment and okay oh i was priest guy
he filled gas twice in the same day
interesting what where are you going he
lives in the moment like you're just i
think on the spot on the go yeah you
know i don't need to plan ahead i need
ten dollars here ten dollars here
he's like not loyal to any gas station
yeah he's not loyal oh cause i go to
different gas stations oh dude the only
thing you got to be loyal to is your
girl and your barber that's it he's the
kind of guy who has like his wallet's
full of specialized credit cards like he
has like 12 credit cards she's on she's
on like the credit card hypothesis when
you're playing the game dude you got to
play to win i'm just not working with
much here i like that he be driving man
i just like want to know more about you
so the other guy the amex avenger amex
alpha the amex alpha he's all over the
map man like that's great because i'm
all over the map natalie who should i
pick oh tough decision for the purpose
of entertainment i'm gonna say guy
number two he could be like a loose
cannon and we like that do you think my
type is loose cannons oh yeah the
candle's never tightened i hate tight
cannons if your cannon is tight
it doesn't go over there you know like
we don't want it yeah if you're just
shooting in one direction i don't like
that you have to be all over the place
bro i want like bang bang bang
chantel two very surprisingly different
guys who do you want to go on a date
with this was a very hard decision we're
gonna go out with uh amex alpha you know
kind of kind of go the safe route so
yeah you picked brian as your date hit
me with this hit me with this it was a
hard choice man you didn't give me much
to work with transparency hey put some
text here transparency is sexy
period i can't confirm that he is about
the culture so and he's got good music
taste was the breakdown correct were we
like pretty accurate maybe he likes
driving
the culture the music tastes like yes
the musical yeah okay all right so we're
actually going to cut for a bit and i'll
let you two go off on your own mini date
and then we'll come back in and check in
and see what you want to do after that
sound good
[Music]
brian you didn't get to see chantal
before this do you feel like credit card
statements are now like a effective way
to gauge compatibility i still feel the
same i feel like it's a good way to
screen people out but i feel like it's
not a great way to screen people in
although i will say that their
psychoanalysis is probably above average
above average psychoanalytical ability
of the credit card statement what would
you like what is that out of ten maybe
like an eight
maybe like an eight like an eight to
weave the narrative to weave the
narrative together you know chantal are
you satisfied with your outcome today
yes absolutely stay safe yeah how do you
end videos
you